it's tough to deliver medication quickly
and precisely to different parts of the
eye traditionally medicine for
conditions like a coma or diabetic
macular oedema is injected into the eye
or drop onto the surface and left a few
slowly throughout this delivery method
isn't always accurate and means the
entire eye receives the drug the process
can be slow irritating and painful for
the patient researchers wanted to build
tiny delivery vehicles they could drive
to deliver cargo quickly to specific
parts of the eye particularly through
the dense jelly called the vitreous
humour so they use nano scale 3d
printing to create small spiral-shaped
delivery boxes
the bots were nearly 200 times smaller
than the diameter of a human hair their
tiny size and a nonstick coating made it
easier for them to pass the tight matrix
of the vitreous humour the spiral BOTS
also contained magnetic material which
meant the researchers could drive them
forward backward left or right with a
magnetic field the scientists injected a
solution containing around 10,000 of the
spy robots into eyes collected from pigs
and put the eyes in a magnetic field
they used imaging techniques into
section to see if the bots have been
able to pass through the eyeballs jelly
all the way to the back where the light
sensing retina lives the thoughts were
able to deliver their cargo to the right
place in much less time than simple
diffusion would allow next the
researchers are planning to test the
spiral BOTS in a living animals eye it
will be years before any humans have
tiny spiral robots delivering drugs to
the back of their eyes but the work is a
step forward in building controllable
vehicles to aim medicine at precise
targets in sensitive areas of the body
[Music]
[Music]